you like this top
so gay
really
yeah it's totally gay you know you
really shouldn't say that Hilary Duff
just transported us back to the early
2000s recreating her viral anti-gay
bullying PSA on Tick Tock I'm like
really proud of it yeah you remember the
one where Hill stops two girls
mid-shopping spree and encourages them
to think before they speak do you like
this top
so gay
really yeah it's totally gay you know
you really shouldn't say that well the
now 34 year old actress took a stroll
down memory lane recreating that clip
this time with the help of Pentatonix
singer Scott Hoying and his fiance mark
menillo
you know you really shouldn't say that
say what I'll say that something's gay
when you mean it's bad it's insulting
what if every time something was bad
everybody said oh that's so girl wearing
a skirt as a top
those are cute jeans though but this
wouldn't be a proper throwback if we
didn't play the new video side by side
with the original what if every time
something was bad everybody said
so girl wearing a skirt as a top
oh yeah
the former Disney star films the OG PSA
back in 2008 for the gay lesbian and
straight education networks campaign to
cut the phrase that's so gay from casual
convos
no you really shouldn't say that but
this isn't the only flashback moment in
Hillary's life lately E.T caught up with
the How I Met Your Father star back in
March and she revealed that her
three-year-old daughter Banks loves
listening to her 2005 album Most Wanted
on repeat she's listening to my music
um
which means I have to listen to a lot of
my own music what's the song the song
right now is wake up wake up
Hollywood
I'm like that's fine we can listen to it
at top top like volume it's it's all
good but it's just you know it's I don't
love having to listen to my my own music
daily and when Hillary's not busy giving
us Tick Tock gold and being Mom goals
she's crushing it at work that kind of
makes me want to cry her Hulu show How I
met your father was picked up for a
second season how excited are you to
keep telling these stories from day one
we all knew we were kind of sitting on
something special once the cast came
together and we were getting you know
deeper into the season and watching the
characters develop like we're like oh my
God we have something kind of great last
month Hills co-star Josh Peck kinda sort
of unofficially confirmed to E.T that
his character Drew will be back for
season two too I think it's sort of
unofficially official and he credits
Hillary for making the experience on set
so awesome Hillary's a dream and I just
feel lucky to be her friend I've known
her for over 10 years and
um and it's just the the entire group
there all the actors the the creators
it's beautiful time and I feel so lucky
to be a part of it
[Music]